hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the meltwater
Champions Chester final series Magnus
Carlson versus Wesley so and this is
their third game the first two games
ended in a draw and this one may or may
not have uh and uh have ended in draw
and it's quite a nice one as one player
uh significantly out prepares the other
players so let's see what happened in
this one uh Magnus with the white pieces
opens with Pawn to E4 we have E5 by
Wesley Knight to F3 Knights the C6 and
Bishop the B5 Magnus goes for the URI
Lopez uh Knight to F6 Wesley replies
with the Berlin defense and pawn to D3
now we have Bishop to C5 and now C3 is
still the most popular idea Magnus goes
for Bishop captures and C6 is Magnus I
believe uh prepare the
um uh for a very very specific client
the captures on C6 and now we have
castles now for those of you who are
maybe new to chess we often mentioned
that if you capture the pawn on E5 you
lose the game that because Queen D4
attacks the Knight and threatens
checkmates to have to give up the Knight
and you you can just resign here in case
you're seeing this for the first time or
maybe you've just started playing the
Berlin uh but here uh simply uh after
this D captures on C6 we have castles
and now Knight to D7 now you have to
defend the E5 pawn and you can defend it
with Queen t7 Knight to D7 Bishop to D6
even Bishop to G4 uh Knight the D7 is
what Wesley plays and now Pawn to C3 and
here uh in all the games pretty much the
reach this position you uh players just
Castle here or Play Bishop to D6 but
Wesley plays A5 and it is only a move
that Wesley plays it's been played only
once before and he played it against
anishogiri uh in last year's Magnus
cross an Invitational that Anish won
with the white pieces but in that game
after A5 just the D4 was played but here
uh Magnus plays Bishop to G5 and it is
now as of move eight that we have a
completely new game so how does Wesley
react to Bishop to G5 the queen is
attacked obviously you can play uh
Bishop to E7 or you can play Pawn to F6
you can't really block talk with the
Knight because then you no longer have a
D5 Pawn defended so here F6 it's a
pretty standard move in in the Berlin
defense so um you know should work in
this line as well Bishop to H4 and the
bishop to D6 now D4 is coming so you
know that um the bishop belongs on D6 so
Pawn to D for Queen to E7 and now Knight
B to D2 We have Pawn to G5 attacking the
bishop Bishop G3 and H5 again very
standard stuff going after the bishop
here trying to trap it with H4 so Magnus
plays H4 G4 kicks away the Knight and
well you could play Knights the E1
Magnus goes for D captures on E5 and
this is since this is a rapid game you
really have to know what you are doing
here uh perhaps even he had this all
and I maybe figured out at home but the
point is that if you if you go for the
exchange G captures and f3e captures and
d6c captures on D6 and Knight captures
on F3 uh black is just lost here it
seems like okay the material is equal
but the position is just uh horrendous
your D6 Pawn is hanging you have to play
Knight to E5 then Knight the D4 is
coming and after something like Bishop
G4 Queen to D2 and there is no way for
black to attack the white king but uh
the black king is in in a terrible
position at some point you will have to
Castle Queen side and then B4 just wins
the game as it uh most often does but
okay Hereafter D captures on E5 Wesley
just played uh F captress on E5 uh and
he relinquishes control over the G5
Square so now Magnus doesn't have to go
back with the Knight he goes Knight to
G5 and okay Knight to B6 uh a for now
paralyzing the queen side as well now
regardless of whether Wesley castles or
not uh Magnus is preparing Pawn to B4 so
Bash up the D7 and pawn to B4 now we
have Pawn the C5 threatening uh just the
capture and B4 but basically asking
Magnus to decide whether he wants to
capture on A5 or does he want to play
something else so Magnus does capture B
captures on A5 Rook captures an A5
giving Wesley the semi-open a file for
his rook and now Queen to B3 and look at
this Magnus has full control over this
diagonal but Wesley has full control
over the A4 Pawn he's attacking it three
times and he can capture it and what
should he captured with with the Rook or
with the bishop it's a very very
difficult Choice capturing with the Rook
is probably a little bit safer but
Wesley goes for best shop captures an A4
he grabs the pawn and now Queen to A2 we
have rooked the A6 so now the bishop can
move the Rook will be defended as long
as the Rook was an A5 the bishop had to
remain on A4 and now Rook F to B1
uh maybe a bit dangerous to leave the
queen on the a file but this is a rapid
game Magnus will force Wesley to burn
time to figure this out uh we have
Bishop to C6 now Shifting the bishop to
this diagonal open opening up a
discovery towards magnus's queen queen
to B3 and now Bishop back to A4 Magnus
repeats a queen to B2 or rather doesn't
repeat he Retreats with the queen and
here Wesley should play King to D7 he
should play King D7 King to C8 and there
the king will be safe as uh it's really
impossible to dislodge this knight from
B6 but instead Wesley played King side
castles and this is now uh where things
can go terribly wrong for him Magnus
goes Knight to C4 and this is the moment
where Wesley absolutely must react now
it seems like you should not be moving
the Knight if you move the Knight then
you lose the B7 Pawn but that's exactly
what you should do here you should
capture on C4 and after Queen capture
Sun B7
uh you can play Rook after A8 and now
after Queen to D5 check which is how you
win back the piece uh King to G7 Queen
captures on C4 and okay the game
continues and it's uh it's a nice
position for black the material is equal
black does have a double C Pawn but it
doesn't look like all that much for
white uh however after this Knight the
C4 move Wesley played King the h8 and it
makes sense at the end of this line uh
Magnus will not have Queen to D5 check
picking uh picking up the Knight on C4
but now Magnus just plays Knight to E3
and now he has access to the F5 Square
which is uh
something Wesley should not have allowed
but interestingly none of the players
actually care about that look at this
Rook after A8 the Wester doubles up on
the a file and now Magnus doesn't go for
Knight F5 he plays C4 he opens up this
diagonal we have Bishop to C6 now
offering trades along the a file Rook
captures an A6 Rook captures an A6 and
now again Magnus doesn't go for Knight
to F5 he goes for Knight to D5 and here
uh Wesley uh has the opportunity to take
control of this because this is not the
most precise idea but you have to find a
very nice Vision too and that is after
Knight captures on D5 e captures you
don't move the bishop you play Rook B6
first you trade off everything and then
you move the bishop for example Queen C2
Rook captures on B1 with track Queen
captures and now Bishop to E8 once you
capture and B7 Bishop to G6 and the game
continues uh it's a very nice position
for both for both uh equal material a
Wesley would have the bishop Fair uh
magnets would have uh well maybe maybe
sort of some attacking potential because
the black king is a bit more white in
the open than the white king but all in
all you should be able to defend this
however after Knights the D5 Wesley
didn't go for this he played Queen to E8
and now Magnus goes to Queen to C3 we
have Knight to D7 now
and after Knight to D7 Ponta F3 upon F3
with the idea of opening up DF file if G
captures an F3 even Rook to F1 and now
you have captures on G2 Rook F7 and you
are just lost your queen F3 Queen H5
there's no stopping Checkmate here so
after F3 we have Queen to A8 now
doubling up on the a file again and now
Knight to F7 with check and there's
nothing Wesley can do here here the
problem is after this queen the A8 move
there is no no going back here you have
to play something like G captures and F3
or Bishop captures on D5 but after this
queen to A8 move there are just so many
moves that win the game for Magnus uh
Knight the F7 check is just the most
forcing one because you see what's
happening uh look at this Knight
captures on C7 is impossible because
Bishop covers C7 but now you just
removed the defender of the C7 Pawn
Knights F7 check King j8 Knight captures
and d6c captures in Knights the C7
attacks the queen and the rook and yes
Wesley does have the Rook A3 freeing
idea but it doesn't matter because
Magnus just plays Queen to C1
with Wesley's Queen still hanging and
queen to G5 check incoming so Queen to
A5 now Queen to d8 is a little bit
better because it stops Queen G5 but
then you blunder The Rook here but if
you want to save The Rook then you just
run into a forced Checkmate it's
actually a force made in 10 here even
though Magnus doesn't go for it but I
will show it Queen to G5 with check and
now after King to f8 uh Magnus played
Knight to the E6 check but the forcing
line is Queen to d8 checking to F7 Queen
to E8 check King F6 Queen E6 checking to
G7 Quinta E7 trick and now finally after
King to g696 with Queen to G7 Checkmate
as the pawns nicely cover all of these
squares but after King f8 Knight the E6
check was played uh okay King to F7
Knights the d8 track King to f8 and now
Knight captures and C6 B captors and now
Rook to B7 and it was in this position
on move 39 that Wesley so resigned to
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here there's no way to defend the
Knight you can't play Queen to d8 the
queen covers that square you can't move
the Knight otherwise you just get
checkmated and if you defend the Knight
with your king you still get checkmate
the queen Jay Chair King E7 Queen to G7
checking E6 and now Queen captures on D7
check King F6 and queen the D6 is
Checkmate as the pawns once again cover
the F5 and G5 squares
so afterwards Rook B7 Wesley resigned
and a very nice win for Magnus Carlson
in the third game of their Match Game 4
ended in a draw which means that with
one win out of four games Magnus wins
his match against Wesley so we'll see
what happens in the next day we're also
going to cover some other games if you
guys have uh any of your favorites do
use hashtag suggestion and I will go
over your comments
um so yeah that's the game I hope you
guys enjoyed it I would like to thank
Jonathan Bradley Christopher Norris
Microsoft Mikhail arboy and Fernando
Gibson for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day